gurov with seven Dy ctle at eight he actually
T of the league leag with mess here's St Coast
a good draw exploded off a stick now a quick
drive and Stam Coast scores and a minute seven
into this game Tampa Bay has taken the lead
on Steven stano's 200th career power play goal
yeah had been 0 for nine in the previous three
games coming in and a couple of things happen
here the stick breaks of Derrick Bryan so he's
already without a stick he's got to stick around
that was almost a tap in right away coocher off
almost found Paul back door you're going to see
Ryan go grab a stick quickly a little bit too
late as this Puck moved around too well by the
lightning and a little bit of a bobbled play in
the slot that they're able to capitalize on that
pass right there mishandle but it's good recovery
by Paul ason into the Zone glendening lunging for
that puck retrieved by ason who's known for his
doggedness mod across to ranish a shot sa get a
rebound Tyler mod I thought it was in I think this
is Count Tyler Ma has scored here two nothing they
have not signal but I believe that's in the
back of the net with the high fives and it's
the shot by radish rebound comes right out to M
and just bounces to him and he chops at it and
goes through a body of De har finds the back
of the net and Pops right out steuart Skinner
thinks he's got it doesn't know that it's gone
in the net and out of the net water bottle and
there you go so M from radish that's his first of
the year Louie take a guess inclusive inclusive
company here's nurse a shot redirected a save on
Fogle by Andre vasileski out the right Pat I mean
he's pretty steady thinking that Puck's coming
right into him with power play in an animated
discussion is Paul on the puck to the Tampa Bay
Lightning taken away by Derek Ryan short-handed
Rush Darnell Nur driving scoring short-handed
goal Editon fourth of the year and the Oilers
right back in the [Applause] game good job All
Around by this team fight for the puck pick it
off Derek Ryan with a nice pass first and then
a secondary beautiful pass by McLoud sorry nen
Hopkins it finds Darnell nurse streaking into
the Zone he protects the puck weights and then
elevates in tight up over top of the blocker
side of vasileski good Patience by nurse the
shorthanded goal scored by Darnell nurse the
only one to get by him here's a quick chance and
there's The Equalizer McDavid right off the draw
and that took one big hop and McDavid made clean
contact no question about it the guys in the
panel talked about they did a lot of good
things in the first first period didn't get
rewarded but now they're starting to create
even more off a faceof look at the effort
to keep this bobl and Puck alive heyman's
in there Newen Hopkins is in there and then
McDavid comes in and just takes out like a
little bit of a six iron right as he kind of
chopped that kept it a little bit low but up
over top and under the bar shorthanded and a
power play goal Lou we talked about it decided
the first game it may very well decide this one
D [Applause] pressure need Hopkins who to drive
scor 32 Edmonton first lead of the night
hman I believe the tip over and keep it
alive once this Puck goes in you're going
to see the stop up and eventually will come
to Le on dry CLE and once he starts to walk
the line he's pressured pretty aggressively
by haggle all over him but he fends him
off makes that pass and then blue Shard
with the bomb once again gets this Puck
settles [Applause] it doesn't move once
he stops and tickles the Raptors against
Nick Paul Stamp go around the boards to
Cher I guess when you're talking about having l
seven scoring Champions on the ice you're going
to have a good game and St Co a midair swipe on
a rebound flurry put it off Skinner and how about
that elad skill stamp Coast out of midair ties
the game he's always had it but here's some good
work again behind the net it's Stam Coast that
throws it out flurry with this quick shot the
rebound bounces up in the air looks like it's
out of Harm's Way that's a pretty sharp angle
too for Steven Stam Co to knock this out of the
air and put it into the net but that's exactly
what he does so the pressing for the lightning
continues they tie this game 33 it's taking some
work they haven't had a lot of chances had a few
more in this third as they continue to push and
it's golfed out by Cerro what a one touch pass
by drle drle this time from Yanmar Co checked
off the stick however goov trying to bust through
Yanmar he'll gain the line CC back good drop took
it home and he did through the wickets of steuart
Skinner and Tampa regain the lead at four to three
as he continues the fight Cody CeCe here watch
this he's got the stick it's tangled up but he
just stays with it and is able to get around
and tap it home and somehow shoved this through
I don't think steuart Skinner thought that he was
going to get to it it's a little bit too slow he
tries to reach with the paddle and it cost him
at that last second as soon as he puts this out
for the Poke check that's exactly when COV jams
at five hole underneath them pointed serach on
the assist aita COV is 20th goal of the season
third in the league stamp Co WR shot score beat
Skinner glove side it's a hattrick for Steven
stamp Co his 12th of his career 5-3 Tampa wow
what a comeback he'll shoot from anywhere and
he picks Corners he's always done that through
his career takes this over the line that stop
and then he uses the screen to get this shot
through Evan buard a little slow to get back
into the shooting Lane as he felt that stamp
Co was going to probably try and thread this
through rushing the puck in Hopkins Kane hman
dry settle and Bard joinan here's Bard wrist
shot deflected score newon Hopkins 54 and still
more than two minutes [Applause] [Music] left
terrific possession entry here by McDavid this
Puck off the draw comes out of the Zone he winds
it up little draw pass by Bard with possession
you find your way to the net and nen Hopkins with
a perfect redirection little give and go but gave
it back to Bard and right here you can see back
door stick on the ice nen Hopkins is available
and the heads up Bard right onto the tape I mean
that is a perfect pass down low to Newen Hopkins
he redirects it past vasileski wasn't easy got a
piece stamp Coast already for the did not get it
out Paul laid it off the glass Celli trying to
find it trying to bust his way through Bard who
went belly down to deny Celli shoots and scores
second effort Anthony Celli and an empty net to
give Tampa 6-4 lead and you can see the urgency
of the lighting they knew they had to finish this
off in the open net with still over a minute and
a half left in this period it was point on the
first one to get in there and then a great job
by Celli pressures Bard to Bobble this Puck it's
up for grabs again he just spins and chops it
towards the net and just relieves some of the
pressure here that Evington has put on in the
last few minutes I mean driving the play up the
ice Yan Mark 10 seconds to go and the lightning
are going to survive coov to Stam Co he shoots
and scores make it four for Steven Stam Co and the
lightning extend to a 74 lead right to The Bitter
End here both both of these teams have battled the
entire game and Stam Coast with a night that's his
fourth as he buries that one in the open net Evon
continuing to try and push every Puck contested
every Puck uper grabs COV with a nice play right
off the wall under pressure and Stam Coast looks
up and says I bet I I bet I found out something
you didn't know cuz I didn't know it that's
his first career four goal game really aren you
stunned that's unbelievable I am stunned by that